gotta love that music we saw the SpaceX
rocket blast-off this morning but this
is pretty impressive too about 300 model
rockets were launched in Huntsville
Alabama the home of the US Space and
Rocket Center it's in preparation for an
even bigger launch of about 5,000
rockets this July to commemorate the
50th anniversary of the Apollo 11 moon
landing speaking of the first man trip
to the moon was of course a milestone in
human history now a brand new
documentary is taking people aboard the
Apollo 11 mission as never before
take a look
I'd like to know what you feel as far as
the responsibilities of representing
mankind on this trip that's relatively
difficult to answer it's a job that we
collectively said that was possible and
we could do and and of course that the
nation itself isn't back eNOS so we just
sincerely hope that we measure up to
that the film Apollo 11 features
high-quality never-before-seen footage
drawn from NASA's archives and the
reviews are as stellar as the original
undertaking was ambitious critics are
calling it astonishing magnificent and
entirely awed inspiring Apollo 11
premiered in IMAX theaters yesterday
opens nationwide next Friday here to
tell us about it the director and editor
Todd Douglas Miller good morning good
morning thanks for having me it's a
pleasure to have you here we all sort of
had the same reaction these images are
so stunning why was this footage just
buried how did you find it and why'd it
take so long to get here well it's a
good question I mean it wasn't
necessarily buried they knew about it
the manager was actually housed at the
National Archives facility in College
Park if you can put yourself in that
place in the late 60s there was so many
Apollo missions that were being made
over a short amount of time that they
were just constantly shooting film not
only this large format stuff 16:35 every
flavor at filling right it was
constantly being processed and sent away
and duplicated you know for safekeeping
and it's really a testament to the
process that they were able to archive
it preserve it so someone like myself
could come along you know and and
discover it this was such a ride I mean
it just takes you on such a ride
I found it's so fascinating some of the
intimate details like the heart racing
or not racing so steady is a rock
heartbeat of the astronauts I didn't
know that the limb was called the
Columbia I mean there were it was just
so fascinating how did you select well
not to correct you but what's called the
eagle was the lamb and the command
module was in Columbia thank you
thank you sorry all the nerds out there
[Laughter]
first of all this footage but we saw
some of the shots there these I mean
this is shot like a movie I mean 70
millimeter footage so this is very high
quality stuff it looks like it was shot
yesterday yeah I mean we owe a debt of
gratitude to the filmmakers and the
cinematographers responsible for the
imagery in fact that was one of our big
research projects when they were working
with NASA in the National Archives was
to figure out where this stuff came from
who was responsible and shooting it so
in the late 50s early 60s a lot of this
large format filmmaking was in vogue
there were really great filmmakers
Francis Thompson Theo can make a couple
of other really tremendous
cinematographers responsible for this
footage and they made you know little
industrial films for it but how did you
decide what to choose there was so much
there yeah I mean the first thing we did
was to actually look at this mission it
spanned nine days so to actually sit
down and edit believe it or not there's
a nine-day version of the film
so our archive team archive producers
working in conjunction with all the
great you know sound designers and other
editors you know on the project it's
just really a testament to their skill
well it really feels like you're there
you really do
it's extraordinary and it must have been
exciting to be in the editing room to
play with all this footage Todd Douglas
Miller congratulations on a great phone
thank you very much for being here
thanks for having me